merci monsieur le président madame la
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues je
crois qu'il faut
saluer le rapport vous l'avez déjà fait
le rapport de nos collègues virginie
klès yves detraigne
sur l'accès à la justice sur la justice
de proximité
ce rapport n'aura pas seulement eu le
mérite de faire appel de toutes les
réflexions qui ont été menées dans ce
domaine il va plus loin et avance des
propositions sur ce que pourrait être la
réforme de la juridiction de première
instance
l'enjeu est aujourd'hui de retrouver un
équilibre entre lisibilité accessibilité
et faut reconnaître qu'il ya beaucoup
d'efforts à faire dans ce domaine entre
accès à la justice et proximité nous
savons par ailleurs que la capacité du
législateur a décidé les périmètres de
chaque contentieux sera déterminante
afin de mener à bien une réforme durable
dans ce domaine la modernisation de la
carte judiciaire qu'il est de bon ton de
critiquer mais en fait que vous n'êtes
pas modifier un à ma garde des sceaux à
une exception j'ai dit à une exception
près moi je ne fais pas de citations
particulière a eu le mérite d'engager
concrètement un processus qui s'était
limitée auparavant une réflexion qui
durait depuis plus de vingt ans aux 25
ans puisque la dernière réforme c'était
59 je crois et je regrette madame la
garde des sceaux qu'on n'a pas été plus
loin notamment en ce qui concerne les
cours d'appel fermons la parenthèse je
vais fâché quelques-uns
aujourd'hui madame le garde des sceaux
cela fait 18 morts vous êtes arrivée à
la chancellerie aux travaux déjà
accumulé songe ajouter divers supports
qui devrait moore de nourrir votre
réflexion bien sûr le rapport que je
viens de citer mais aussi les réflexions
la directrice elle fer judiciaire sans
oublier le rapport guinchard il ya eu le
rapport
cazorla que vous citez ou encore les
débats relatifs au report de la
suppression des juridictions de
proximité pour autant attendez vous la
grand-messe de janvier vous restait
encore flou sur les orientations que
vous allez donner à la réforme prochaine
de la première instance est-ce qu'on va
créer un tribunal de premier instance en
globules ratti l'ensemble des
juridictions de proximité tribunaux
d'instance
prévu d'autres commerces conseil de
prud'hommes malgré les réticences des
juges qui sont élus dans certaines de
ces juridictions dans le cas où cette
juridiction disposerait d'antenne
déconcentrer ça peut être aussi une
hypothèse comment allez vous dépassez
les risques d'inconstitutionnalité
relatifs à l'égal accès de tous à la
justice et aux principes sacrés
d'inamovibilité des magistrats du siège
c'est peut-être beaucoup des questions
d'une seule madame la garde des sceaux
mais je pense merci beaucoup très bien
modano ministre
oui monsieur le président je vois
permettez moi de prendre quelques
secondes pour saluer le sénateur vallini
et le rassurer sur nous avons été
informés des incidents qui vient de
survenir et la direction des services
judiciaires seront immédiatement sur
place
monsieur le président y est il ya eu
d'effondrement de l'effondrement d'une
passerelle entre les bâtiments
judiciaires et une personne blessée
monsieur monsieur le président y est
alors sur eux la jussie de proximité
c'est une réalité vous dit quand on
critique la carte judiciaire je n'ai pas
encore fait mais je vais je vais je vais
dire je renforcer ce qu'a dit le
sénateur mazars la réforme judiciaire la
réforme de la carte judiciaire n'est
contesté par personne elle était
nécessaire la méthode a été mise en
cause y compris d'ailleurs par les
magistrats y compris par les cours
d'appel qui avait travaillé qui ont fait
des propositions des suggestions il est
incontestable que dans certains
territoires cet art judiciaire cette
réforme de la carte judiciaire a créé de
vraies désert judiciaire et les déserts
judiciaire aucun d'entre nous ici ne
peut s'en accommoder puisque c'est un
éloignement de la justice pour le
justiciable alors vous avez évoqué il ya
eu des ouïes des vocations un peu sonore
en tout cas audible à ma place sur
les décisions de voilà deux ouvertures
de tribunaux pas vous mais vous avez
toujours c'est élégant cela monsieur le
président je vous la reconnaît mais
puisque j'ai la parole je réponds je
rappelle que les conditions dans
lesquelles j'ai fait procéder à l'arrêt
a vu réévaluation de la situation de
certains territoires
ces conditions sont absolument objectif
je me suis contenté de faire réévaluer
les villes qui avaient fait l'objet
d'observations de la part du rapporteur
public devant le conseil d'état pas une
de plus pas une de moins voilà c'est aux
critères objectifs et puisque j'ai
entendu évoquer tulle tu le fais partie
des trois tribunaux de grande instance
effectivement que nous allons rétablir
avec saint-gaudens et saumur tué quand
même la seule préfecture qui ait perdu
son tribunal de grande instance alors je
crois qu'il ya plus de questions sur les
raisons pour lesquelles tu l'a perdu son
tribunal que les raisons pour lesquelles
tu y vas retrouver son tribunal de
grande instance les éléments sont
parfaitement objectif pour justifier la
réouverture du tribunal de grande
instance de tulle donc nous combattants
c'est désert judiciaire et via plusieurs
réponses effectivement l'excellent
rapport de madame place et de monsieur
détraigne offre un certain nombre de
propositions les chantiers que j'ai
ouvert la réflexion ce n'est pas une
grand-messe monsieur le président y est
la justice mérite que nous mettions les
intelligences ensemble elles méritent
que nous mettions les énergies en somme
elles méritent que nous travaillons
ensemble à améliorer les conditions dans
lesquelles justiciable peut avoir
recours à la justice et ce que nous
faisons vous êtes largement invités à
cet événement de janvier qui sera une
étape parce que à partir de ce travail
effectué en public de mise en commun de
ces réflexions sur la base et préconise
des préconisations de cet acte de ces
quatre rapports pardon je vais ouvrir un
cycle de concertation je me déplace des
gens juridiction les assemblées
générales vont traiter de ces sujets
dont nous avons nous allons avancer mais
la méthode est vraiment l'écriture
commune merci je suis président
soyez bref si vous le pouvez oui madame
le garde des sceaux j'ai bien entendu
mais moi vous savez je me méfie beaucoup
des conférences de consensus et c'est
parce que
non la loi c'est ici quand j'entendais
ce matin un professeur dans un colloque
dire que dire que le
législateur n'a qu'à faire les lois pour
à la ligne et tout le reste il ne s'en
préoccupe pas on a aussi la charge
d'évaluer avant ce que c'est quand même
notre métier pour faire une bonne loi il
faut savoir de quoi on parle et s'il ya
des rapports d'information aussi
précieux et je crois monsieur le
président que le sénat s'est toujours
illustré dans ce domaine c'est aussi
parce que nous avons nous une expertise
et pas seulement celle des spécialistes
et quand j'entends je vous le dis
franchement quand j'entends que ça
devrait être les magistrats qui nous
dise comment il faut faire
je pense que autant je respecte le
magistrat dans son activité
juridictionnelle autant le corporatisme
est un bel exemple de cette noble
corporation
il y en a pas et seul mais si on demande
aux professionnels de se réformer vous
savez très bien que ça ne se fait jamais
et donc c'est pour ça je sais très bien
ce que vous allez faire au mois de
janvier j'essaierai d'y même d'y
participer vous voyez mais il n'en
demeure pas moins que ça n'est pas le
lieu où
les décisions pourraient être prises
c'est un éclairage ça doit s'arrêter là
de mon point de vue très bien merci
merci monsieur boris diop